foreign
[Music]
thank you very much for inviting me to
this virtual event today my name is
Cyril delay I'm a postdoc in the
University of California San Francisco
in the laboratory of Professor Alma
barati we are dealing mainly with Mike
Felix
and I'm talking today about my most
recent sales sequencing method that I
developed and I showcase some
applications in cancer biology and in
infectious diseases
so if we think about cancers cancers are
genetic diseases driven by somatic
mutations
and through the efforts of large-scale
sequencing consortia
consort chairs we now know the genetic
underpinnings of about 95 of the the
common cancers that we encountered
so this puts us in a situation now that
we basically know the genomics of the
cancers but we need to find a way to
translate this wealth of information
into better understanding of the biology
of these countries and especially
interclinical benefits
so what's the challenge in that
well
cancers are incredibly heterogeneous
tissues composed of multiple distinct
cell types and different cell clones
and if we now take an average
measurement over such a cancer tissue we
essentially convolute the signals from
all these cells together and therefore
such a profile is not very
representative for the underlying
biology of these cells
to solve this is conceptually very
simple we can simply disaggregate the
the tumor tissue into individual cells
and then look at them independently and
that should give us a much better view
of how these different clones act and
what their biology is
so how can we do that that's where
Dropout like Athletics re-ended the
scene
microfilic droplet droplet microlytics
is just a tool that's very efficient at
creating small compartments and so you
can use these droplets these
compartments in order to segregate
individual cells
and therefore isolate them from each
other for the analyzes
now if I talk about that a problem like
physics and single cell analyzes most of
you probably will immediately think of
single cell RNA sequencing since that
has been risen to Great prominence over
the past couple years I for this reason
I won't explain it in detail because I
think most of you probably know how it
works roughly just very briefly
conceptually again we encapsulate single
cells in Rockets we add or basically we
add to get the attempt together with the
so-called barcoding bead the barcoding
bead brings in a primer with a unique
droplet specific barcode and this allows
you then to create a cdna library using
this barcoder primer if you sequence the
collection of all these cdnas you can
then use this barcode to reassociate the
RNA profile with a particular droplet
wherever the cell of origin basically
however I went down this path to single
cell sequencing because we wanted to
understand how a cancer genotype drives
its physiology and which essentially
means the first thing we need to achieve
is to get a measurement of the Single
Cell phenotype of such a cancer
now you in principle you can do that
with RNA sequencing however that's
really not ideal because due to a number
of technical issues
um RNA is just a very poor
um shadow of of the information that is
present in the genome so you really want
to look at the DNA of these single cells
but the problem with looking at the DNA
in single cells is that the genome is
compacted into the nucleus it's bound to
many proteins chromatin nucleosomes and
all of this creates an incredibly
inhibitory environment for molecular
biology basically the reactions we need
to perform in order to barcode these
these molecules for the Single Cell
readout afterwards
now the standard way of dealing with
such with the chromatin DNA extraction
is to just use a very harsh lightest
condition this essentially strips the
DNA from all the protein components
makes it available for the reaction
however in this case the the harsh
lightest condition is in itself very
inhibitory to the molecular biology that
we would want to do in order to bark
with the DNA
and so the way the Avatar lab solved
this issue was by using proteinase K so
what we can do with protein as K is we
simply encapsulate the single cells
together with proteinase K solution
and then we we incubate these droplets
off chip for a while which gives the
protein is K time to digest the proteins
thereby Liberate the DNA and then we can
heat and activate protein it's K to this
probability provides us an off switch to
turn off these harsh like these
conditions
we then Harvest or use these droplets
and re-inject them in a second device so
these either right the droplets coming
in from the top the containing the
cellular analysis and they are paired
with a secondary droplet that is just
formed on the chip containing again a
borrow coding bead and a PCR reaction
mixture
we can then Harvest these droplets again
these profits contain the same barcoding
beads so the bar coding bead is a
scaffold putting in again the primaries
each primer features a droplet specific
barcode sequence and then a targeting
more edited moiety that targets one of
several up to several hundred cancer
hotspot genes that came from these
consortia sequencing experiments
so we target the whole thing
simultaneously so in essence what we
have in these droplets is there for a
multiplex PCR that simultaneously
amplifies the genotype of these cells
and provides a single cell barcode
we can then after the PCR Harvest again
these droplets and extract the amplicons
and what we would like to see is equal
amplification of each of these um
of these Targets in all the cells and
over all the targets and so what I'm
plotting here is on the x-axis the
different targets about 50 that we were
targeting in this case and um and the
the box plot gets the distribution of
the applicants found in in the in real
cells what you can see is that this is
this distribution is very level
indicating uh equally well amplification
of most of these targets and that
ensures that we have very high
sensitivity in detecting the genotypes
and gives us the possibility to resolve
the hypotype information since since we
will be seeing both copies of the genome
simultaneously with high probability
so
what what does that give us at this
point well that's exactly the same thing
as what people would be do be doing if
they do bulk sequencing Target bulk
sequencing of cancer cells but we
through the barcodes we have this now at
single cell resolution
and um I guess for those who of you who
have heard of mission bio which is a
startup coming out of gibati lab they
basically recently commercialized this
microphobic workflow
um describe them but I have described
here
so what can we do with this with these
kinds of measurements or experiments
consider this um this patient with acute
myelin leukemia
this is a fish plot
over with three different measurements
on the left we have a diagnosis sample
in the Middle where the fish is thin
there is a remission and on the far
right we have a relapse so if you look
at the diagnosis sample you can see the
color coded there are four different
clones present at the original sample
each other with a distinctive type now
if you look at the right side at the
relapse we see that the colonial
compartment has changed dramatically
compared to the diagnosis sample and in
particular we note that the the majority
of the cancer cells are now composed
from these red clones
and in fact this red clone is already
present in the beginning of the
diagnosis sample with a very small
proportion of cells and this basically
indicates that this clone was never
effectively treated with the treatment
regime that was chosen in this case and
seated to relapse
now this I find very interesting but
what I really would like to know is why
do these clones await treatment what
makes them special really
um to succeed at
seating this relapse later on
and to understand that I think the
genotype is is not extremely not enough
information because we basically already
know from the central dogma of molecular
biology that although
DNA contains all the information it's
translated into the cellular phenotype
in protein space or in in functional
space through multiple regulatory events
and all of them influence what will be
retained or like will arrive on the
right end of this information flow and
so if you really want to understand the
phenotype of the cells it's probably not
good enough to just measure the DH
genotype what we need to do is correlate
it with a phenotypic readout
and so what we decided to choose as a as
readout is the protein space for two
reasons first of all it's on the far
right of the diagram so it incorporates
most of the regulatory events or
Upstream so all of these are
Incorporated in at a stage in the sort
of the information flow and second
proteins is the interface that is
amenable to treatments most of the drugs
act on the proteins so that's probably
clinically the most relevant
aspect of the phenotype in some sense
so how can we measure single cell
proteins at a single cell level a very
classical way of doing this is by using
a fax machine so the idea is you label
antibodies with fluorophores you can
stay in cells with these antibodies and
then you flow and flow these cells
through fax machine which allows you to
detect the fluorescence profile for each
cell which can be translated in an
immuno profile and if you want you can
sort these cells
and so this would in theory allow you to
for example sort out a distinctive
immune compartment even the phenotypic
compartment and sequence it in order to
associate the individual time
however these things were encumbersome
and it seems it can only really work if
there is a tight connection between the
immuno phenotype and the genotype
um then that's yeah basically the only
way such an approach could resolve the
connection of phenotype to genotype
so we thought Adam and I how can we can
we make that better how can we have a
more General solution
and so what we thought of was abseek a
method that the ability lab has
previously developed so the idea behind
antibody sequencing is that you can
simply swap out the immuno floor the
floor for an antibodies for a DNA
barcode
and now if you use the sparkled
antibodies to label single cells or
cells
this allows you again to switch out the
floor fluid sense detector of a fax
machine for a sequencing machine and
therefore convert essentially the signal
into sequencing space
now with that idea in place it's very
straightforward to come up with a
workflow that can profile single cell
genotypes and immuno phenotypes
simultaneously because all we need to do
is to stay in cells with these antibody
DNA intact antibodies and then apply
them to the microfluidic genotypic
genotyping workflow I just described
previously
if we then harvest the the droplets from
this workflow what we receive is again a
multiplex PCR in droplets the aspect of
the genotype is exactly the same as we
described before but in addition we get
a second reaction that the spiraling
with another primer on the antibody
barcodes that are present in these
droplets and so after sequencing we
receive two kinds of matched matrices
both are like have a cells or any
columns and then we have a categorial
vector for the genotype calls genotype
can ADP vile type heterozygotics or
alternate for any good measured position
and the antibodies are just conflict
areas that we have the detected number
of antibody power codes for each
antibody and each cell
now because we can measure many more
antibodies than what you can resolve on
a fax machine you can go up to hundreds
it somewhat cumbersome to interpret this
data in the similar way as within the
facts result and therefore we use
summary statistics or dimensional
dimensionality reduction algorithms such
as for example the uniform manifold
approximation and projection algorithm
in order to analyze and investigate the
data and so just to give you an
intuition behind this how umap works the
idea is
um it's basically a probabilistic map
that attempts to
um map cells that are closed or similar
in their profile in the high dimensional
anti-story space into a closed
neighborhood in the two-dimensional
representation on the right so what we
expect to see is that similar cells
should sort of visually cluster together
in in this case
and so what we see here looks like
they're free such visual clusters
present in the humor and that's exactly
what we should expect to see since this
is from a proof of principle experiment
that I did on
um on Cell lines where I mixed together
a Milo itself the kefa 62 a T Cell line
and the B cell lines since these
Airlines have different immuno profiles
you would expect to see that with good
absolute readout that we do in DT here
now in addition since cell lines are
derived from distinct patients they
inherit the genetic Fingerprints of
these people
therefore we should be able to map the
genotypic differences between themselves
on top of this human representation
and that is indeed the case so as you
can see for example for this key it Gene
we have three different genotypic
signatures one of the wild type cell one
of the heterozygota cell and one of the
alternate cell and they map exactly
between one Affinity compartments
defined by the antibodies of these three
cellons so this essentially then proves
that the method works
with that in hand I approached Professor
Catherine Smith and Cheryl purse both of
them are hematologists in the UCSF
and ask them if they would be willing to
collaborate on a on a small case study
to see if he can learn something
exciting from from some patient samples
and what they have been working on
recently was this case where they had a
patient that was treated for over a year
until uh it's a it can a case of acute
myeloid leukemia after one year they
finally achieved permission
but then unfortunately about four years
later the person relapsed and the cancer
came back and so I I analyzed these laws
for time points uh indicated here in
blue
[Music]
so at the top you can have a
representation of a fish plot and what
we can immediately see from the dot seek
result is that the chronal compartment
of these patient was composed of from a
single clone so only one genotype with a
mutation in the MP and one gene
now if we look at the immuno phenotype
at the bottom in the umap representation
we again get the the immune Affinity of
the compartments for the normal cells on
the right and then a monofinetyptic
signature that is characteristic for
these kinds of cancer cells and
interestingly over the whole treatment
time occurs so these four samples like
processed from this patient
phenotype for every minute very much
constant so all the time the cell is not
back to the same compartment
and even more interestingly we have a
very clear separation in the immuno
profile of dcd-33 marker between the um
healthy cells on the far left and the
cancer cells in red
this is particularly interesting I guess
in this case for for clinicians because
there is an antibody group targeting
cd43 and since these cells separate so
while that makes this patient very much
amenable to treatment by this kind of
drug and indeed that's what has been
used on this patient or the final time
point it's called chin to the map
as you can see this puts this person
into remission so that was a great
success
um next next I looked at a second
patient
which allows in this case the
the the
flow study that the clinicians typically
do
um
in the course of the diagnosis
uncover the atypical blast compartment
meaning that the immunophenotype was
somewhat uncommon
and so I subjected these same samples to
the datseat experimental workflow and
again you have a fish plot at the top
from what we saw the genetic side
again
um the cancer
clonality was relatively low we have
essentially two clones
non-composed out of an empty-free
mutation
and then a subset of these have an
additional npm one mutation again now if
you look at the bottom at the umap
representation of this initial time
point at the diagnosis sample you see
that the cancerous clones in Orange are
mainly contained in this atypical blast
compartment however they are also
distributed throughout other blast
compartments on the top right and
especially also through more healthy
immune signatures
and so that's very much different from
what we saw in the first patient because
in this case we have basically no
correspondence between the equivalent
phenotype and the genotype of these
cancer cells and as you can imagine
uncovering a situation like that would
be extremely hard if you you need to do
it sequentially for example by doing a
fact sorting and that genotyping of
these cells
um really highlighting the kinds of
information we can gain without seek now
um
in addition when we follow this patient
a bit longer along his treatment history
we see that in the third umap in relapse
sample or like at the fish plot at the
same port time point in the relapse the
Clones acquired an additional mutation
in different free Gene flip-free is
signaling gene mutation which is
relatively common commonly acquired in
relapsing AML clones again
and as you can see this dramatically
changed uh the immuno phenotypic profile
of these cells and now we have again a
much more clear cup relationship between
the immune phenotype and the genotype
I I
um so this is really interesting for me
to see that um
that there is this descriptive penalty
especially in the first time point
between
the genotype and the phenotype and it
really highlights that tools like these
are necessary in order to have any
chance to disentangle these complex
relationships between the two cell types
but between genotype and phenotype
now of course these are just one or two
patients that it's only suggestive
they're not a statistic but while I was
working on this I also shared a method
and collaborated with a group in Boston
who had been working on a patient cohort
on 120 or so patients and in one of the
major results they they also saw that
typically acquired mutations in the
signaling genes left foot free for
example caused a shift in the immune
phenotype so I think that's something
that people will probably be following
up following up in future
now as a particular design decision we
did in the development of this method of
us that we we basically built it on top
of this commercial uh microtic system
information bio in order to enable
non-expert groups non-like vertic expert
groups to to use the technology for
their own questions and it's really
satisfying for me as an engineer to see
that many Publications came out over the
last year that already picked it up and
applied it to their research questions
so for the second second few last few
minutes of my presentation here I um
switch gears a little bit
because it occurred to me
um that the capability to measure
genotype together with a phenotype could
be actually quite powerful outside of
the field of cancer biology
I was particularly thinking of
infectious diseases and the
intercellular proteins where you
basically have a foreign genetic entity
hijacking a cell and sort of trying to
modulate it for its purposes
and so I was thinking of particularly of
HIV HIV is a viral pandemic that has
been ongoing for for a long time it
still has caused more depth and the
recent kovit pandemic
um
and so it seems like a really valuable
and interesting Target
now HIV can be treated with the
so-called on Direct Revival CRP over art
art prevents the viral life cycle and
you're up to write a life cycle but it's
not the Cure so people need to need to
take these pills for Life basically
and this is only about half the world
population has access to this kind of
treatment
um the necessity for a cure is still
chronic demands
so what's how does the life cycle of HIV
roughly work so once you get infected uh
the viral load shot shoots up as
depicted here in this red curve and the
and HIV immediately establish
establishes a so-called latent HIV
Reservoir
so people think that the CD4 T cells are
the major cellular component of this
Reservoir which is basically integrated
viral DNA in the Genome of these cells
and HIV in this forum is very persistent
the antiretroviral therapy can Target
the red part the viral load but not the
reservoir so that stays consistent and
if now people interrupt their art
treatment the viral load shoots up again
and this rebalance out of this HIV
Reservoir
so if you want to treat HIV what we need
to do is finding a way to Target the
reservoir or to silence this Reservoir
what is so what's the problem there why
why can't we just do that
well these CD4 plus T cells uh harboring
the HIV buyers are incredibly rare so
it's we think of them as one in ten
thousand so it's probably infected
um
then they don't the HIV in this form
doesn't express any proteins or RNA so
there's basically no way how we can sort
and sort these cells or identify these
cells and subject and converted studies
the only unambiguous Market that these
cells have is the integrated Pro virus
which is again like a DNA copy of the
virus in the in the human genome
this raises the question can we make a
assay that exploits this molecule to
identify these cells and maybe in
addition learn something useful about
the physiology of these cells or find
ways that we could use use the target T
cells and of course measuring such a
genotype along physiological aspects of
cells is exactly what dapseek does
so for this reason I designed a panel of
targeting primers that are spanning the
age of each genome
with 10 targets this is not that easy
not as easy as the the cancer targeting
panels because HIV is so variable in its
genotype they are in its genome that
it's hard to find a spot where it can
place a primer
nevertheless there are multiple
conserved regions that are useful for
for this kind of purpose and so the idea
here is that since we have 10 amplicons
simultaneously that increases the
probability that at least some of these
will work and it also provides the net
possibility to distinguish truncated
virus defective or basically defective
virus from fluent viral integrates
I again made a mock system to see if
these
system could work in detecting HIV cells
and for this purpose I created the pbmc
I used the blood sample pbmcs and spiked
in one percent of chill out cells
chill out these HIV model cell line with
integrated virus and so again the
dapseek readout here shows the immuno
phenotypic compartments we get the cell
types that we expect malate the cd8
killing T set these killer cells B cells
and so on we can hear an additional
cluster of cells that indeed Associates
with a very high number of detected HIV
amplicons the median is age detected
amplicons from HIV D cells
and so that might that's likely the jail
out cell line
um spiking and again since these jlr
cells are derived from different
patients than the blood cells they
should feature a different genetic
fingerprint which we can again detect
with the human panel that is also
present in these measurements and that's
what you see on the right in the the
Sunland it is high in HIV amplicons
HIV amplicons is also positive for these
these genes like different these genetic
markers
again a reinforcing the notion that this
is the trailer outside line and the
method works
I then reached out to Professor Ian
Clark at the UC Berkeley at Professor
elac Boris
to participate in a in a studying
patient samples and so we assembled our
seven patients from The Raven cohort The
Raven court is a court of HIV patients
on long-term art that means they had
it's an effective viral suppression for
over two years and so we aimed to
profile some 100 000 sales per patient
in order to have a decent number of
latently infected HIV cells present
um here I give you a sneak peek of the
kind of data that we are seeing from
these studies this is the blood
compartment from one of these patients
again you have the expected blood
compartments we see more CD4 T cells in
this case than what you saw before in
the PBC sample since we enriched these
we pre-enriched these cells because we
suspect that the HIV is mostly present
there so we wanted to make sure that we
give the best chart at identifying these
cells
so you can ask yourself where do you
think HIV is in this
if you look at it if you look at the
genomic readout we detect HIV
exclusively in these
cd4tc uh Central memory compartment
this is very exciting it is also what
you would expect
um from what people have been doing
previously but with dapseek we are able
to show that um
in addition to just being here in the in
this compartment language it's basically
exclusively there and we also see that
the HIV infected cells are actually
enriched in a special subset of the
which available here the the South
Central memory compartment type two
um which is even more enriched in HIV
cells so I think this is really exciting
um
and it will be very exciting to follow
up on this and see if it can detect any
relevant markers for these kinds of cell
lines
um so if that I I basically conclude my
discussion for today
um
I hope I convey to you that that this is
a really exciting field to work within
and that there is plenty of
opportunities for method development and
mic products in order to make uh attempt
in the analysis of these challenging
diseases it's very exciting to work in
this field where so many different
expertises meet
I am
want to thank especially my mentors Adam
abathi and Dean Clark
um
and also my colleagues in divata lab
especially Ben and Harish who helped me
in a lot of these of these experiments
and I already acknowledged my fantastic
collaborators through found the
presentation and don't write there some
support and funding sources thank you
very much